the jurgen experience
i'm interested in that i'm very
interested in that and i'm not saying
those people are lying and i'm not
saying that john mack
introduced ideas into their heads but
what i am saying is
the real evidence the real evidence like
the video of that thing whatever the
[ __ ] that tic tac was
taking off right at what they estimate
to be thousands of miles an hour
instantaneously
from a standstill and jetting off to the
cat point
where they were initially supposed to
meet
like the this the coordinates that the
jets
had where they were supposed to scramble
to doing this exercise
this [ __ ] tic tac went to that spot
almost like to tell you hey [ __ ] i know
where you're going
it went from they tracked it on radar
going from 80
000 feet above sea level to 50 in less
than a second
these are with known visual visible
propulsion systems slipping 180 degrees
which is
you know in physically possible with the
technology that we know exists
no heat signature right no propulsion no
known vis
visible propulsion system they don't
know what the [ __ ] these things are
so if these are super advanced us
military craft
wow holy [ __ ] have they been working
holy [ __ ] did they create something that
defies
all known physics that we have today
in terms of like what's a what's
available for propulsion
because everything else is you got to
push something out the back whether it's
flames
and that makes things go fast forward
this is everyone describes it the same
way
even back in the 50s and 60s it was all
described as
similar types of things that would
disappear or shoot off
yeah that doesn't seem physically
possible but now
what's so weird about it now why are
like former cia directors
like brennan woolsey even obama has like
made
like a joke about like yes we don't know
what these things are
what do you think it is why is the
intelligence community coming out and
actually like
putting their stamp of approval on this
when for the last 70 years it's been so
under the radar they
you know they've been putting this under
wraps but now they're kind of
toying with the idea like we actually
don't know what these are
and then they also say we know that
they're not from our military so they're
hinting toward adversaries right china
russia with the hypersonic weapons
technology that they're claiming that
they can develop weapons five to ten
times the speed of sound
yeah and i don't know what that looks
like when you apply it but
that's strange to me that you see this
roll out
in the mainstream media talking about
this now with the disclosures that the
pentagon has put out
now you are a cynical person especially
when it comes to the u.s military and
the intelligence agencies
what's your perspective like i'm sure
you're not just saying oh
well they're looking out for us yeah
they want us to know about these uh
amazing things like what's your cynical
perspective
well when i look at these things a lot
of these people i believe
these people and especially watching
that documentary joe is a real mind [ __ ]
and a lot of this is bone chilling
because i believe especially when 62
people see something or people
200 people in melbourne australia or all
of these
high-level military people who you could
tell are scared shitless recounting what
they saw i believe them
i really do because it's hard to act
right
but my mind tends to go toward
what is physically possible is it a mass
hallucinations is it some sort of dmt
weapon that can elicit some sort of mass
hallucination where people are
um susceptible to a delusional mindset
and
told something like you just said is it
the hypersonic weapons technology is it
something that is a drone being
projected holographically
is it something that we can explain by
uh
you know the realm of quantum physics
that we actually don't understand like
like the schrodinger's cat phenomenon
like is there something
that is within the realm of physics but
we don't understand and can't comprehend
it yet so that's where my mind goes in
terms of what is it
if it is something from another planet
is it holographically like projected
onto us
you know is that is that what's
happening but in terms of the
intelligence community and people like
marco rubio
with that pbs special that came out or
the 60 minute special and marco rubio at
the end of it is just like
we don't know what these are man they
they might not be from our planet and
i'm like
what the [ __ ] like one of the most
hardcore neoconservatives
yeah is going out there and acutely
toying with the idea that this could be
from another world
and knowing that this has been
so under wraps that whatever is
happening and i believe something is
happening has been
completely censored and covered up by
our government but now
they're coming out and saying it's okay
to talk about this this is no longer
some fringe kooky conspiracy theory
this is happening of course the cynic in
me goes to
what better way to kind of pull on our
deep-seated psychological fears of
something that we can't explain this
kind of supernatural element to whatever
is going on
going back to the the the ufo lore of
everything from x-files something that i
grew up on
you know the abyss like this notion that
if there's something greater
than our government and our
technological capabilities then we need
to kind of like just acquiesce toward
our institutions to be like you just do
whatever you need to do whether that be
militarizing space like these things are
a threat
just because they exist and we don't
know what they are so so my mind goes to
there's a reason why this rollout is
happening and it's not for the
betterment of humanity and it's not
because of the curiosity of these
officials in terms of learning or
wanting to find out what ufos are it's
about
going back to what i said before it's
about militarization and and
you know space force was basically part
of the neocon blueprint back from p-neck
the bush administration and trump
fulfilled that dream
and i do think that this is this is part
of that and
and look i don't know but i think that
we need to ask questions
why is our reality being sanitized why
are things like q anon being purged from
the internet
as ludicrous as it may be but we're also
simultaneously being told
that ufos are something that are real
and they're concerning they're
potentially a threat to national
security we don't know what they are
and it's okay to talk about that now
that is a curious thing to me
joe it is curious and i i appreciate
your perspective
because i think it's good to look at
this from a bunch of different angles
because
it's real tempting to say well i'm
finally
at a point in history it's amazing i'm
i'm here where the government
is admitting that there are alien
crafts that are off-world vehicles
not from this earth you know that was
like one of the quotes
that were we're admitting that we're we
have
we're being visited but are we
because why would the [ __ ] government
finally start telling us without
motivation
without some sort of end game without
what what's what's what's in it for them
to tell us about these things unless
they're so frequent and so bizarre and
so many military people are talking
about them
that they feel like their back is
against the wall and they have to say
something about it because otherwise
they're going to lose credibility
that there's so many of these things and
there's so many like the go fast video
the flair video
there's so many of these encounters that
these very reputable people like
commander david fravor
have had with these crafts that behave
in a way that is
impossible as far as we know with any
known technology on earth in 2021 and
this is
the david fraver one is from 2004.
what's disturbing about it is no matter
what it is i don't think we're going to
find out the truth and i think it's
going to be exploited for
for certain means that we're not going
to know it's not going to be overt but
there is definitely something going on
because it doesn't make sense and and if
it's oh there's so many people seen it
[ __ ] this has been going on for 70 years
i mean yeah
that movie i mean there's people like
every day one thing that i find really
interesting though is
now everyone has cell phones that film
in 4k
google earth satellites all over the
world that can zoom in on someone
walking down the street
so if these things are flying over the
ocean like someone
uh you know part of the david fravor
special on 60 minutes was saying i saw
this
[ __ ] like this every day that was a
literal quote from him
why are we only seeing these grainy
satellite images
of these ufos well christopher mellon
who used to work for the state
department told me that they have way
more [ __ ]
way more footage they're just not
releasing it
but why why roll out this one and where
is this grainy film
satellite they're not rolling it out
it's it's soldiers
it's sailors it's it's fighter pilots
it's people are releasing these f
videos and photographs they're leaking
them because how come they're not
getting into trouble for like leaking
them you know like we had
like this is a whistleblower leaking
these because it's
i think it's a different kind of a leak
it's not like they're leaking something
the united states is doing
right they're not like like you remember
that kid that got arrested for taking a
photograph inside of a submarine
remember that that's a different kind of
leak right that's you're leaking out
u.s military secrets this is not a us
military secret this is a strange
unidentified what they call a uap now
because ufo's got a bad rap
right it's like red pill got taken over
by [ __ ]
you know so now they're these a lot of
these people that have seen these things
are frustrated at the lack of
transparency i mean this is the
narrative right i don't know if this is
true but
my friend jeremy corbell who's been the
guy who's released most of these
most of these videos like those
pyramid-shaped crafts that they were
watching with night vision that were in
the middle of the [ __ ] ocean
floating around over this um destroyer
or this
aircraft carrier they don't know what
the [ __ ] those things are these these
are videos from people that are there
the one the the one that was a um
trans-medium vehicle
that was flying over the ocean and then
went into the ocean
they don't know what the [ __ ] that is
they filmed that thing with night vision
they don't know what it is and this was
soldiers
that were filming it enlisted people who
were filming it and you could hear them
saying like what oh yeah
no they're no they're splashing down
it's in it's in the water now they're
like
[ __ ] and the water yeah like the whole
like wild yeah the water to air
yeah stuff doesn't make sense either
without compromising the function of
like one or the other that
it's very fascinating but what i guess
my point is
if they're seeing the [ __ ] every day you
think that they would try to film it
like
you know not on satellites this is what
the point they
don't have the ability to film it on
satellite
they only have access to their cell
phones they have access if you're going
to
film it on their cell phone but they are
filming some of these things like that
one that went into the ocean
that's i mean that's the best they can
do with filming something off of night
vision
the ones that were floating around above
that ufo or about
above the aircraft characters shaped
like pyramids about the
the you know the the go fast video i
mean they're using the
the cameras that are on these fighter
jets that are designed to track
enemy craft and that's what they're
designed for they're locking in on this
thing with their tracking systems
this thing's moving at the same rates of
speed and they're following it
this is the best that they have in that
application
now that doesn't mean that the
government doesn't have some satellites
that could
zoom in on those coordinates and get
that thing and get a very detailed
high resolution video of that they
probably have that
if these things really are real if they
aren't [ __ ]
if this isn't just some sort of a mass
psyop
if that's true they probably have some
really
high resolution [ __ ] that will curl your
toes and that's what christopher mellon
says
but there's no reason for them to
release that stuff for two reasons one
why would they tell why would they give
away
the actual capability of these
satellites
in uh like an undeniable way like if you
could see
like the [ __ ] bolts on this ufo from
you know
however many miles in the sky these
satellites are and you then everybody be
like jesus christ
like what else are they watching what
else can they see you know they can
watch you take a [ __ ] through your
bathroom window what are they doing
you know if they can see that like they
can read a license plate from space
that's what's been reported that it is
possible now
through these satellites that you can
get such a high resolution video that
you can
clearly see a license plate from space
and
read it clearly that there's also
something called claytronics which is
like a programmable
matter like micro computers that can
create a holographic
cloud that's actually a tangible
hologram i mean there's so many things
that
seems like it's centuries off
uh it's this is what they're saying that
they're working on
developing where you can have a series
of microcomputers
program themselves into different visual
entities
into one giant hologram that was a
spider-man movie
yes no i know you know yeah the reason
no this is this is no this is crazy [ __ ]
man i mean chris carter the creator of
x-files says that he had like a cia guy
like feeding him information
for the show i mean i do think that art
imitates reality in a lot of ways
and when it goes back to the 60 minute
special which was one of the only
mainstream institutions that was taking
this seriously my whole thing is like
there was no skepticism at all there was
no attempt
to debunk these people which seemed like
a
change in tone yeah from these
institutions like so that that like
blows my mind it's like usually you
would have people
have the debunker have the guy saying
that he saw ufos
but this one was just like glued in
being like this is happening
well the new york times is the first to
break it in 2017 that really shifted
the perception when you see the new york
times has
an article talking about these
unexplained vehicles
and taking them seriously and then
interviews with like high-ranking
military officials people from the
pentagon all that kind of [ __ ]
when you see that stuff start to make it
into the mainstream it just changes
everything the new york times
for sure changed everything that 2017
article changed
the people that would never take ufo
seriously
they're seeing that in the new york
times and they're saying like holy [ __ ]
this is in the times yeah these are the
same people who discredited dennis
kucinich at the 2007
presidential debate because they were
like you saw a ufo like you [ __ ]
idiot and that was one of the
questions and he was like yeah yeah like
i saw a ufo and it's like
dude yeah jimmy carter ronald reagan all
of them saw ufos too you know and it was
such a discrediting
fringe thing but but no i mean it's it's
not
at all